hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father not crazy mad okay well anyway
we're going back into this room and I I
kind of feel bad about just leaving her
here but at the same time she's fainted
I'm pretty sure she'll be just fine so
anyway carrying on
lovely father oh hi mom how you doing
good you look good you look good
got color hey you wait okay is that
really mom probably there's no way I
mistook her that was mom
why was even mom it must be the curse
right right
haven't you noticed who the hell are you
this tragedy was brought about by the
power of a woman's curse the malice for
your father the Maoists turn to occur
seeking out your father's death could
that woman be so you to realize yes your
mother that can't be why do you think
that because mom loved father mom even
understood father's work and father love
mom in return wasn't mom happy I
couldn't believe she has a grudge
against Arthur but maybe mom didn't like
father and Mario yeah maybe that one I
don't want it to be true but
so you'll go find the truth yeah screw
you
hey wait those jump back there I'm gonna
go find it again I need to go back who's
a gem I saw jump oh those you oh hi
moving no longer seems like a husk
creepy almost beautiful got a gem now
right seven I think is the total number
I've got feels like you could start
moving a sleeping person arrived so now
let's find out what's in here look lots
of bodies I guess that's why they called
the corpse room is that a head well
nobody if you're so gross so I gotta
pick one of these witches your body is
that set the game we're playing here big
buddy I don't know not brave enough to
look inside let me guess what was that
what oh hey look I [ __ ] huh come on come
over here over here buddy
I'm here come on
come on gimme right here oh you're
already going to get it found it okay
don't try to kill me
I helped you thanks mrs. your you're
welcome weirdo have a good day nothing
strange about that yeah I got a jam all
right okay what am I looking at now
stacking wood crates filled with junk
filled with junk not everything's junk I
saw that can fool me saw it I saw it
I saw it you know the looking in things
sound it sounds so happy and jovial oh I
didn't even know there was a bird there
big barrel hey I got a ladder I can use
that for the ladder piece or for the
Attic the attic ladder
I think there's anything else here okay
why is it always so dark has it got to
be dark
where you going need a ladder here wait
a min where does this go hey I got a
feeling that I want to go back because I
think I saw gem up in the attic area so
I want to make sure I get that done
first and foremost as opposed to maybe
moving forward and not being able to
come back that's that's important I
think are you done you don't good
there's something under her skirt hi so
why are you doing oh girl stop that
that's rude got a room key
cool maybe I can unlock one of those
locked room yeah you better run looks so
sad yeah all these corpses look sad but
they're still dead you don't want to be
messing with them cuz you kind of burned
all of their friends alive or dead dead
live you burned them mister owns it okay
so this key goes to one of the rooms
yeah let's go to the Attic first hi
again where are you going going that way
alright I'll follow up all yes I'll
follow you whoa okay how's it going
buddy um hi I think he was trying to say
something the key goes to this room
thank you for leading me right to it
that's awfully nice of you
is this Maria's room Maria's diary yeah
we'd the diary doctor it has been a year
to the day since I came to this mansion
I will never forget that day
dun-dun-dun-dun so I think our something
about you being picked up on the street
or something like that
please food
food somebody food somebody and then the
kindly doctor decided to help you out a
bomb a bomb she could be a fine subject
with some work spit a hole see one so
skinny come to my home please I'll give
you clothes and delicious meals sounds
too good to be true
then he'll Banga Banga i don't know why
he would want to cheat on anyone
when this doctors got such a fine wife
but oh well why not sleep with the bum
you
Oh God be in the same room with a zombie
stay here a little while tell my family
about you family I have a wife and girl
turning seven I'm sure they would
welcome you family
you still look weird lady you're in
there with it like a dead guy probably
not good who is this person like me move
hug what awful injuries it must hurt
perhaps I could do something to end his
pain you mean woo woo with you my skirt
won't be enough cloth but the only other
cloth I have is your underwear
I'm surprised it was about to die but he
recovered overnight it seems he was
given excellent treatment how could you
do that did you treat him yes how handy
you're exceptionally talented please ah
hi I couldn't let this go to waste
what's your name Maria Maria hmm an
appropriate name Maria would you be my
assistants Oh I do not wish to lose you
please stay with me will
well will you entrust me with the rest
of your life that's a pretty steep
commitment there buddy it's pretty
pretty big Simon to say by the way I
wanted to clarify so I said I didn't
mean to say that like bums are dirty ins
Barry if you're if you any of you better
been homeless it's a horrible thing and
I applaud anyone who's managed to climb
out of that very bad thick that's not
what I was trying to say all I was
trying to say is that he has a hot wife
so why would he need to cheat that's all
the time saying try for you Jamie I was
alone but you made me you gave me love
as long as I'm needed I will stay with
you how could I live without you now I
could see how this happened I love you
doctor
and she wouldn't be too bad-looking
either if weren't those of giant creepy
eyes anyway that's all I have to say
about that read her diary heard some
backstory about Maria and I never really
knew anything about Maria after all
Maria must really love father to all
right so maybe that's gonna help with
something towards look look at the bed
okay so was that all that I needed to do
there okay that was a long way to go for
some side story there but if we can help
release like a better ending towards the
end then I'm all for it okay so I'm
going to the Attic going to the Attic
dun dun dun dun the only reason I
clarified about that is because I didn't
want people saying like high marks and
insensitive doers I'm like no that's not
what I'm saying at all so I don't mean
that still sounds weird yeah yeah use it
also I have this wooden bucket that I
the wooden bucket for the well outside
because the bucket had a hole in it
yeah I'm gonna get another Jam
I got a gem I'm gonna get all the gems
I'm gonna try okay there's got to be
something else here besides a gem right
really oh whoa I can smash this on the
move throw it up throw it off the edge
smash yeah yeah it's more like it okay
do we got here well we got here huh this
is a myth uh-huh a mini chainsaw what
wha make aya swing the chainsaw down
certain object barrels empty crates can
be destroyed okay I'm not gonna get all
the gems because I'm never gonna use the
creek you cannot be used to attack
enemies be aware that you can't open the
menu and check objectives with the
chains without special kisi or shift
confirm Kesey okay so see in Zee
airspace see in space I don't know
so alright another flashback really um
um oh sorry sorry
aya what are you doing tween that around
sorry
this is not a toy it's very dangerous
never play with this again so sorry
father
glad you're not hurt it is odd though I
thought this would be somewhere that was
out of your reach where on earth did you
find this aya
I'm sorry I'm sorry father ah I'm so
disappointed in you
uh ah uh ah some my mom always said cuz
my mom's Asian oh yeah there was a video
that's it's like [ __ ]
Asian mom saying so ah ha ha ha ha okay
anyway we got a mini chainsaw that we're
gonna try out okay I can't use it here
I'm gonna go outs you're right there
what happened I felt like something
grabbed my leg not good crawl crawl for
your life I'm pushing I'm pushing use
your mini chainsaw what's it a sort of a
cab what do you want from a thank you
Oh bababa too too bad I would go with
you but I would go with you Bao so
anyway if there are so many flashbacks
being in this back garden then why was
it hidden behind a painting and why
didn't I remember that it was hidden
behind a painting that's what I want in
yo that's what I would like to know and
yeah okay I'm gonna use the wooden mama
okay I was on the wrong I thought for
sure because it's it was a hole in that
but maybe yeah I am smart
I'm really really smart oh wow what why
is this what I can't deal with what am I
gonna do with this gonna put it in the
well what ah I guess it wouldn't make
sense for me to just put a big bucket of
water in my hand skirt what uh-huh I got
a really oh oh I can put the fire out oh
okay
yeah alright there we go another gem
Boosh gem why I like it go in the
fireplace that's not a good idea
Oh everything got big hear a girl
weeping from the hall so what do I do
about that
eyeball bottle I check some pendant what
do I do about this what do you want want
from me I noticed that uh one thing
about this game that um I've restored
more of them in the witch's house it was
so easy to just die all the time no
something it was really cool about the
game till I was there a few more like
instant death scenes from this one it
would just make it a bit more
interesting not saying that this isn't
good is a very very good game but I'm
just saying I kind of miss I always
thinking about that as soon as I'd stick
my head in there
walk good and dead okay so was that that
was the only reason I needed that but I
don't have the rec was an item to give
the lady so that she will stop crying I
thought maybe she wanted some tasty
eyeballs but apparently my eyeballs
aren't good enough for her what the hell
okay if you enjoy some eyeballs from a
kind stranger okay so I've made not a
lot of progress
I will admit up and kind of backtracking
this whole episode alright I will part
the VR just a little bit longer you guys
can see what was up over here oh that's
the ladder okay I wasn't sure yeah okay
when can I use the mini chainsaw no idea
I unlocked the door with what I didn't
have it what ah come on
whoa I was a big circle for nothing I
could have gone that way the first time
I thought there was something special
over there but I'm all out of time so
thank you all so much for watching click
iam Jason for more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
ah
ha
he
this key pintia for anywhere
have the Kiwi